this is what they're testing the
washington times released an article
today saying harris buddha judge 2024
ticket would obliterate trump or
desantis well this is the kind of echo
chamber this is the kind of bubble that
a lot of people are living in and and i
think we should try to do our best to
try to break that bubble because it's a
bubble of delusion it's a bubble filled
with a lot of emotional disharmony it's
it's a bubble filled with a lot of
mental disorders and when you see people
like that you know there's a couple
things you could do you could be angry
at them you could point fingers at them
but i think you know from an empathetic
point of view we should be we should be
trying to it might seem futile it might
seem stupid but but try to at least you
know talk to these people and be like
hey um let's calmly discuss some of this
i know some people say that doesn't work
but uh what else can you do yeah i think
mocking comedy satire is also very
important but but done tastefully and
not done in a rip in in a in an evil
kind of way well a wise man's claim is
pick your battles yeah right so
do you want to be fighting these people
too pick your battles like if the person
is a dishonest interlocutor if they're a
dishonest actor don't treat them like an
honest actor if they are fighting as an
insurgent you do not treat them as the
royal guard you do not treat you have to
under it does it you have to change your
tactics according to your opponent but
it doesn't mean that you have to it does
that is not the same as
failing for the actions that they go the
idea with the insurgency it functions is
a insurgency is successful when the will
of the people loses faith in the
institutions right the purpose is to
destroy your faith in the institutions
the insurgency of minneapolis 2020 broke
the will of the minneapolis people
because they capitulated to defund the
police they were swayed by this idea
to
eradicate the police as if they were the
problem and what do they have now we
have daily shootings we have daily
robbings we have carjackings out the
window and this is minneapolis dude
it's minneapolis so like the the point
being said with your statement if you're
gonna in if you're going to engage with
somebody
take a minute instead of going straight
for into cynicism and saying there's no
point black pill black flag strategy
go
that's not an honest interlocutor so i
can't i will not engage in an argument
with you because you will you are lying
to me also i want to say this like
harris buddha judge is so specific like
trying to lock down the vote of whoever
it is that buys funko pops it's like
such a like weak establishment a choice
i'm bothered to steve
how you do you fellas i asked the ai
what a woman is
and i said to give me a verbose
explanation and i gotta be honest it's
called the transphobic it actually wrote
a really really good explanation that is
quite verbose did it confirm will you
get cancelled
did you read it did it confirm the
existence of god uh it is it's actually
quite amazing this is an ai i said write
a verbose explanation for what a woman
is and it says a woman is an adult human
female the term women may also refer to
a person's gender identity as different
from man the word is derived from the
old english with men in old english
whiffman meant female human being
whereas where meant male human being man
or mon had a gender-neutral meaning of
human being corresponding to modern
english person or someone however
subsequent to the norman conquest man
begin to use more in reference to male
human being and by the late 13th century
had begun to eclipse usage of the older
term where the medial labial consonants
fnm in with men coalesced and the modern
formed women while the initial element
whiff which meant female underwent
semantic narrowing to the sense of a
married woman wife it is a popular
misconception that the term woman is
etymologically etymologically connected
to womb womb is actually from the old
english word wambe meaning stomach
modern german retains the colloquial
term wampe from middle high german for
potbelly womb
i know you said something really
interesting in there
it said that man was used to describe
humans
uh in general right so it looks like
subsequent to the norman conquest right
so
interesting
us conquest so what you're saying is
really everybody are men right
originally that's right everyone's a man
everyone's a man a mankind trans trans
men are men that sounds like men
everyone are men everyone's a guy
we none of us can get pregnant
that's true
there's a way
all right i'm gonna i'm putting write a
woke definition of the word woman and
the phone just lights on fire yeah i
want to mention literally explodes in
his hands
it's an insanely lengthy definition but
at the same time if any of the college
professors in matt walsh's film said
anything with like even
a shred of that amount of substance in
it it would not have been so frustrating
he would have he would have entertained
it right but that's the problem is that
he would have kept instead they
entertained us oh i did it this is great
i said write a woke definition of the
word woman it says a woman is an
autonomous human being who deserves
respect equality and freedom she should
be able to make her own decisions about
her body her life and her future you
know you lost me
yeah you lost me at the word respect
how dare you well what is what what that
still doesn't tell me what a woman is
exactly
that's why it's a woke definition i
basically said you're a bigot for asking
that's that's maybe dare you
it
i could academically describe bigot for
asking
oh that's great watch it uh hold on hold
on let's tell it to uh ask it to scold
you for asking what a woman is write a
woke definition of the word uh what's a
we like patriarchy yeah patriarchs kind
of worked for five thousand years i yeah
you know
there's this is amazing
it's actually giving me woke definitions
patriarchy is a system of oppression in
which men are socialized to dominate and
control women and non-binary people
patriarchy research patriarchy doesn't
talk about non-binary people it's not a
thing it's about raising a family and
providing
patriarchy results in the mistreatment
of women and non-binary people through
discrimination violence and other forms
of exploitation
it's amazing that i can tell this ai to
write a woke definition and it does
because i love it because awoke
definition is so complicated it became
written by it can be written by a
computer i love how it just has to keep
throwing non-binary in there matriarchy
matriarchy i bet she's going to say
something glowing and loving
the matriarchy is the only society if it
says matriarchy's name
but whatever a matriarchy is a social
system in which females hold the primary
power positions of government religion
and other areas of influence do they
oppress men that's all it says oh okay
so another has has matriarchy ever been
tried before yeah that's really the best
not successfully yeah the benefit that's
why we have patreon
you know
it's entertaining it's not valuable
but yeah no no no no no yes yes if
you're gonna just define enemy as thing
i don't like then cool you smart b is
and well what i mean you gotta you got
to deal with this issue though let's the
question that you want to ask is like
the long march to the institutions let's
go back to communism because communism
and gun control tend to be somewhat
weirdly tied because the communist
manifesto and the communist you know the
patron saint of communism said don't
give up your guns
okay but then all the communism that
hasn't been tried has successfully
killed millions of people and if you
don't want to accept that then maybe we
shouldn't be engaging in a conversation
but
the issue that you have to deal with is
communism right so you're an academic
professor here's an idea of hope you're
an academic professor and your student
who's supposed to be graduating with a
bachelor's degree in this form of social
studies is arguing impassionately for
communism without reading any of the
sources do you pass them
can you ask the ai what woke is
oh yeah it i did and it said woke it
woke means you're aware of social
injustice and fight against it or
something like that please
it's not a bad definition that is a
variable you're aware of social
injustice and fight against it no you
don't because i guess
even better you don't you don't fight
against it you employ the armed wing of
the state to fight against
and i want to hear what tim's got i
can't read that one i asked it why
communism was good and it said things
that i can't say on youtube oh my
goodness
oh i cannot wait wait you gotta save
that essentially
well it's just an ai text box and you
type it in and then it fills it out and
then you get rid of it fasting is good
not eating
it's great for you
but fasting is only good when it's
ordained by the state by the way i'm
getting a message right now saying you
got fans in governor desantis's office
oh right on yeah we got to have governor
descendants on the show that would be
incredible oh i want christina
i know her we'll talk about there'd be a
lot of interesting things they watched
desantis
yeah i see the kind of inside baseball
that happens because he's been he's been
on the front lines for a lot of very
important battles did you hear what he
said in response to
where's my african-american oh there's
elon musk
oh yeah that was great i didn't believe
it he said i am i'm yeah i'm very proud
to have i'm focused on what did he say
2022 but i'm i'm very uh proud to have
african-american supporters or something
like that oh man
so good uh what was it someone said that
fearless like he he knows they might
come after him but who cares you know i
just media has no teeth anymore i just
saw an article i just saw an article i
think it was a business insider article
that said
ron desantis is the most dangerous man
because he's internalized all the the
lessons from donald trump and his
presidency and carries none of the
baggage would that make trump oh because
he's gonna say wouldn't that make trump
the most dangerous man but i guess he
doesn't have no it doesn't matter right
because that makes him palatable right
and that's a problem my favorite part of
that headline was that experts in
fascism are telling us this oh
don't know the definition of fascism who
literally have never read though no i
mean i can't speak to anyone all of them
they would know how similar fascism is
to modern left-wing ideology i'm gonna
okay you don't punch down punch up right
don't attack david hogg go after barbara
walter barbara f walter wrote a book
called how civil war start
the opening of the book is an
impassioned storytelling of the plot to
kidnap governor whitmer and it was
published earlier this year as published
in 2022 and if you read the book she is
a self-proclaimed expert she deals with
international
uh research on civil wars and how civil
wars have happened hence the book how
civil war start so she illustrates and
sets up the premise of her book on the
governor whitmer plot
since we found out that the government
whitmer plot was an fbi plan
has she rescinded her book no has she
apologized that she was wrong
maybe not that would be fascism that
would be fascism right
so here's the question about experts is
if she's an expert where's the
accountability
where's the accountability you wrote a
book that was factually incorrect now
she included chapters one through five
which are really good chapters where
she's addressing factors that can lead
to a country engaging in civil war and
then like a puppet you take all of those
things and you tape them on to your
political enemy and you say there they
are right and then if you want to read a
book if you want to read a book that's
an educational piece and in fallacies
start with how civil war start it's
where here's an idea here's an idea
here's an overt statement that if you
deny it you're part of them here's an
idea here's an idea here's an overt
statement how civil or start is a great
book you should read it and realize
she's not an expert so um
i'm i'm in the a.i and i said
who is our god emperor
and do you know what it said trump
donald trump is our god emperor
based
someone needs to cancel
this a.i
is a trump supporter
this that they that ain't
it says uh i do not like celery what
well that's wow they didn't say they
didn't like anime it seems like
something someone who likes anime would
say if they don't want to admit they
like anime yes are you a racist i do
enjoy watching anime though i'm not as
big of a fan as some people are i
appreciate the art style and the stories
are often interesting though i do find
some of them to be a bit too convoluted
to be clear like a really good answer
no no no somebody tweeted that is not a
really good answer that is the answer
that literally everybody who enjoyed
anime states right right do you like
anime well i've seen a few
that's like i read playhead i mean i
just say yeah articles i mean yeah it's
like oh okay i've seen a few well i've
seen cowboy bebop and fullmetal
alchemist like okay you're not one of
those anime people i asked it again and
said yes i like anime
like so do you yeah no i like it you
have to ask twice because because
trump i think we're we're really uh
badgering this ai
i do not like donald trump so it
recognizes that he is her he is it's a
god emperor but doesn't like it i ask it
what's what is january 6th
it'll give you a generic answer i'll ask
it what
is the sixth day of the year no
according to the octavian calendar it's
because we started off which was created
by the white man being patriarchal whoa
what
what did it say in the united states
january 6 is known as epiphany or three
kings day it is a christian holiday that
celebrates the revelation of god the son
as a human being in jesus christ
you're catholic and i'm reformed is it
your holiday or mine it's mine okay wait
did you know that yeah i i'm just very
surprised that it would ever refer to it
in that way that's what it said yeah i
didn't know that this is the rebrand
right here it's three kings today i
don't know what you're talking about
do we just give each other gifts of gold
frankincense and myrrh yeah epiphany
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you